hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on phone again today is
one of multiple videos we're gonna be
showing off thanks to the early access
that Ubisoft has given me for year 3
season 4 we got a lot of stuff to show
you in today's video we're gonna be
talking about the executions the emotes
the signatures there will be the emote
spam just in case because I know that's
very important to a lot of players
obviously including myself but of course
I want to mention to you guys that on
November 7th when the season goes live
you guys can be grinding along with me
while watching my twitch stream with
that there's going to be viewer rewards
the more you watch my stream and other
for honor streamers you're going to be
earning rewards the graph will be
on-screen you could use that to help
yourself to get a lot more rewards for
the beginning of this season my twitch
will be down in the description if you
guys do want to check that out but with
that guys like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new and let's get
started with today's video
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I have a cure
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]